All of our friends had
left us
and we
were both stuck there.
I mean, Napa Valley of
all places,
but that's
basically how Carlos and I met.
I am very happy to
meet you.
Also, I'm finished.
Oh my God, Grandma,
no, Carlos is not a busboy.
He's my boyfriend.
I'm so sorry.
Amy, it's okay, she grew up
during a different time.
Tell him to start mowing
the lawn by the pool
so it'll be
quiet for my nap.
( announcer )
Look familiar?
Are you tired of your
elderly relatives
thinking their
blatant racism is okay?
I don't know how to help my
( bleep ) grandma!
There is an answer.
Generations.
A revolutionary new facility
where we give
your elderly loved ones
the politically correct
social skills
to get along
in the modern world.
This person is what?
Drug mule.
A gardener?
No.
Latino.
In our
state-of-the-art facilities,
we use an obstacle course
to teach them
fear-hiding techniques.
No!
We'll show them hard evidence
defying stereotypes.
Okay, everybody,
now watch very closely.
Somebody help him!
I'm perfectly fine!
( applauding )
Thank you
for your concern.
He's so
articulate.
That's not a compliment.
In our
two-week Asian intensive,
your loved one will first learn
what words are "never-says."
Chinaman.
That's a never-say.
Orient--
Never-say.
Here at Generations, through
repetition, patience,
so much patience,
hand-holding, gentle cajoling
and coupon reinforcement,
we prove that you
can teach an old dog new tricks.
Here's my new class now.
Bitch, I'm
trying to help you.